puede considerarse este informe como
transparente porque Israel se rehúsa a
iniciar una investigación criminal
Qué tal Buenas noches y muchas gracias
por invitarme al programa transparente o
no lo que en esta situación es que
probablemente el asesinato de aguacles
quede impune las autoridades han
determinado nuevamente que rechazan la
autoridad del crimen en virtud de la
situación en la que se ha envuelto es
decir un contexto
descrito como confuso y rodeado de
intercambios de fuego con militantes
armados Esto no es lo que describa el
personal de al jacira y otros testigos
que se encontraban en el momento del
incidente pero lo cierto Es que la
muerte de abu apk se entiende Como una
especie de daño colateral y de esta
manera lo que establecen las autoridades
israelíes es que aún ante la alta
posibilidad que un soldado israelí fuese
el autor material hecho que asumen o
bien es indeterminables saber
exactamente cuál de los soldados fue o
bien Eso es anecdótico porque de todas
maneras no considerarían que el hecho
sea un crimen sino nuevamente constituye
un resultado aceptable en una situación
de adentro contra grupos categorizados
como terroristas y en un clima
decrecientes hostilidades entre
población civil árabes israelíes con
población judía israelí y palestinos con
israelíes ahora como es recibida esta
decisión en los territorios palestinos
bueno probablemente Podemos esperar
protestas y otro tipo de manifestaciones
de rechazo de por sí la autoridad
nacional Palestina a través de su
presidente más muda Bass a también
repudiado
digamos el resultado de esta
investigación y lo ha categorizado como
un intento más de las autoridades y
relieves por evadir lo que aduce es su
responsabilidad material en el caso de
este crimen no Y de esa forma Lo
encadenan junto a otra serie de Hechos
de los cuales también se culpabiliza a
las autoridades por otro lado la familia
de aguacler está
exigiendo a las autoridades
norteamericanas que han venido
presionando al gobierno israelí a llevar
a cabo una investigación independiente
que sea parafraseo las palabras de la
familia exhaustiva independiente
increíble es decir se están valiendo del
también era ciudadana norteamericana
para mostrar que su muerte es una
evidencia más de que tanto las vías
palatinas como las norteamericanas en
cualquier parte del mundo se hayan
Igualmente vulnerables es decir que
deben intervenir finalmente la cadena al
jacira
cabe mencionar a también expedido
exigido que un organismo internacional
independiente investigue
neurolansky Cuál será ahora el paso
siguiente para quienes exigen justicia
en el caso de la periodista qué
instancias posibles quedar muy
brevemente por favor
sí muy concreto Entonces la familia de
agua que es como decía probablemente
exija a las autoridades norteamericanas
a que el caso sea
llevado investigación una vez más y
probablemente apelen a la Corte Penal
Internacional hecho que la autoridad
nacional Palestina ya también mencionó
hace unos meses creo que el mes de julio
Pero bueno desde mayo desde que ocurrió
este incidente Esas son las
posibilidades que se barajan